are you finding that these revelations
that you read
about uh at the weekend given what
you've been told are pushing you
ever further towards uh the decisions
that
have been made by some of your
colleagues including luciana
berger and potentially looking at the
work
of the tiggers
um do you know i really do mourn
the loss of luciana berger from the
labour party and the others who went
some of my very closest
friends and colleagues chose to leave
the labour party
but this is a very individual decision
and for me uh i'm getting an age now
i've been a member of the labour party
for 56
years i joined the party because i
myself am an immigrant jew and this was
the party that seemed the natural home
for jews it was a party's
values were about fighting racism
promoting equality and fostering
international solidarity
and i'm determined at this point in time
to continue the fight for the values
that i've been a member of for so long
let me just also say this the party's
been around
for over 100 years now uh this
leadership has only been in place for
over three yeah so are you saying
you know it's a long life for a party
absolutely but you're
saying um from that day margaret that
you are not
planning on leaving the labour party any
time
soon they were your natural bedfellow
and you're gonna stay there
i was very careful what i said kay and
what i said is i know that's why i'm
pressing you on it
i want to carry on fighting
i at this point in time i want to fight
for the soul
and the heart of the party that i have
worked with and served in for 56 years
at this point in time indeed so you're
not saying never say never are you
i'm not saying never say never what
would have to change for you to think
that you know what
i've had enough of a party that i have
loved for 56 years
and it is time for me to look elsewhere
for a better fit
well at this point in time
i want to fight for the party that i
have worked with and worked for
uh and you know served my serve that
all my adult life um you know
to restore it to the values that brought
me to it
when i joined those were 56 years ago
those are
eternal values you know you may have
different policies at different times
but those are eternal
lasting values and um i i'm
i'm in for fighting at the moment for
those values
and what is so important about this
anti-semitism
is that um it's sort of you know there
are all sorts of reasons for it
it's always been present in the heart
left i mean i've experienced it
on occasions through my throat my years
in the labour party
but it's been on the fringes of the
party and what's happened under the
current leadership
is that somehow permission has been
given for those views to move from the
fringes to the mainstream
yeah so what would let me push you one
more time and then i'll i won't push you
further margaret um
what would have to change with the
labour party as it stands
for you to consider looking elsewhere
beat the tiggers or whoever else
um i would have to feel that i could not
restore the soul and heart of the party
to the values that uh made me join it
uh 56 years ago and at the moment you
feel that you can
i'm going to carry on fighting i'm going
to carry on fighting
i am a fighter i've shown that in
various things
i mean i fought the fascists and the bnp
in 2010
i recognize that you know anti-semitism
is a huge problem across our society
very prevalent on on the right but what
is so
unacceptable and horrific to me is that
it is emerged
um strongly and into the mainstream
of the left now and that's what i'm
determined to
eradicate and fight to
ensure is not tolerated by anybody
in the party finally what do you think
about the action of the tiggers
i can completely understand why they've
done that um
i i really do mourn their departure i
particularly mourn the departure
of uh luciana but you know some of the
other people
who went are among my closest and
and and dearest friends and colleagues
um so i do mourn it i understand that
people have to
you know people are in different places
in their own journeys that they take
different decisions at different times i
just want to fight at the moment and
that's the decision
that's right for me and i hope it proves
right
the labour party too